[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants avez vous été sage
au patron vous leur demanderez tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas l'heure d'être sage
c'est l'heure de jouer
et bien va vite joué gros impatients ou
les seuls au monde
à
l'eau sur la terre je suis bien au pont
de vaux répond
il n'est pas prêt ce soir de repartir on
it s on peut entrer et oui atteint les
indiens et bien j'arrive
seul qu voir
messier services monsieur venance servi
c'est tout pour moi gashi
cas mathieu s'asseoir et
va ça vient doucement
c'est par quelques terres ocres api bon
c'est un turc ou n'aiment pas ça qu'on
enlève les carottes râpées merci nicolas
tu es un ami alors je prendrai bien des
spaghettis à l'italien ou oui tu es
spaghetti à l'italienne al merveille
[Musique]
vous êtes monsieur oui
doucement doucement hausse un peu plus
encore un petit peu getty le
laissez moi on respire
je vais la chercher
adresse en
com vous savez
quel fils nicox mais que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui mais on donne nos
attaquantes
et voilà l'image
des champs comme ça tu dois me rappeler
le mot pas leur truc
de
ouf ne la passionne pas on va encore de
gatti non je vous en prie plus de mort
ont alors des petits
oignons caramélisés
[Musique]
à notre tour papa
puis son truc car amélie tu ces petits
fours
messieurs préfère c'est une menace je
les attends
[Musique]
une glace à la fin du stage
j'arrive pas trop
je crois que j'ai trop mangé
de la voilà messieurs vous êtes copains
on vous a gardé au oui merci les enfants
je vous promets que je reviendrai
souvent
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors gros gourmand pas trop
excusez cette expression qui n'est pas
très correct mais vraiment
j'ai fait humble ton alors en route
bonne nuit des enfants fin de beaurains
oh
[Musique]